I still believe in the power of
forgiveness I believe in the power from
redemption to offensive thing today I
manned up and tried to accept
responsibility for the errors of my ways
and I still believe in the resurrection
that was former Illinois congressman
Jesse Jackson jr. after being sentenced
to 30 months in federal prison for
campaign finance fraud he's the son of
civil rights activist Jesse Jackson
senior and Jacqueline Jackson the former
congressman served eight terms in the US
House of Representatives from 1995 until
his resignation in 2012 now he and his
mother are sharing how they got through
this prison sentence in a new book it's
called loving you thinking of you and
don't forget to pray letters to my son
in prison the book features personal
letters that Jacqueline wrote to her son
every single day during his in concert
and during his incarceration
Jacqueline Jackson and Jesse Jackson jr.
join us to discuss welcome thank you for
having us I want to give my son some
more lipstick that I gave him yesterday
come on no mom I won't do that but I
want to talk about the reason why I
wanted to talk about this book is
because neither of you intended for this
to be a book Jesse when you were sent
away to prison you even said to the
family forget me leave me alone I don't
want any communication because you were
humiliated and embarrassed you said just
forget I thought I thought Gil that I
had brought enough shame enough
embarrassment and I was ashamed I was
catatonic during that period and I
didn't want to be remembered I didn't
want to be a burden for my children I
didn't want to be a burden for my mother
and father just let me go to prison and
let me be and my mother was determined
not to abandon me and I saw men in
prison who were abandoned and she was
determined to write me everyday and
pulled me out of the very dark place
that I found myself in and you wanted to
do that why Jacqueline well I ran into a
17th century poet his name was Richard
Lovelace mhm
and he said stone walls do not a prison
make nor iron bars a cage and it was a
poem that he wrote to here
love Althea and the poem is called to
Althea from prison mm-hmm and he was
simply saying this point this where you
are your circumstances will not define
your character this is just a bump in
the road and the difference in a in a
stumbling block and an obstacle is on
how it is in how high you lift your feet
so we are going to get through this and
you're going to be much better as a
result of this experience well what
struck me about the letters was the
simplicity of them just day-to-day stuff
do you have a window how large is your
bed in your bedroom is there a bathroom
in your room and you locked away why
haven't I heard from you or Thanksgiving
was almost uneventful into your call we
missed your present president so we
didn't laugh as much what did those
letters do for you I think you know when
I went into prison and I was receiving
them every day they were sustaining me
they were giving me a sense of what was
happening at home when I got out of
prison and reread the letters I reread
them for perspective my mother was
sharing with me that again the
circumstances of incarceration were not
defining of who I was but Gail I saw men
in prison who were not receiving letters
they were not receiving communications
and every day again at 4 o'clock at mail
call they would say Jackson and Jackson
and Jackson and I would watch men who
were excited about the prospect of
receiving mail but the only one who was
receiving mail was Mays yeah so I would
give them my mother's letters and say
this is what my mother has to say about
all of us today yeah but I love how you
say Jacquelyn this was a stumbling block
it really wasn't a stumbling block he
was a grown man you weren't you were
convicted of stealing campaign taking
money from your own campaign seven
hundred and fifty thousand dollars so it
wasn't it was a self-inflicted wound
there's no doubt about it and I accepted
full responsibility for my for my
behavior have you thought about why you
did that you know over ten years that's
the nature of the offense and the
government concluded about $75,000 a
year were expenses that were not
justifiable and rather than drag my
family through that entire process
it was really a long build-up to some
depression because I have to tell my
mother at some point in time just how
extravagantly I have been living and
that I'm going to prison I shared it
with my father first I refused to share
it with her until I finally broke the
news to her and that was very painful
you also said Jacqueline Jacqueline that
maybe he felt he wasn't living up to his
father's expecto sexpectations all
parents have high expectations for their
children you don't give birth to trash
mother's love their children and there
are millions of women who shared the
pain and still share the pain that I
shared during this experience and what
we are trying to do now is put a dent
into recidivism 72% of the young men and
women who are incarcerated return and we
don't want that to happen so you're not
exactly what he did either I think I
think that that's very important to say
you're not - yeah crime causes hurt
justice repairs and we need to begin to
look at the our sister the penal
institution as a place to repair and
make people whole we have that is the
purpose of this hangout a deal you
started a good conversation we'll be
right back